Çeviri: Nihal Aksakal
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Her şey bir ahırda başladı.
İnekler var güçleri ile bağırıyor ve
ahırın kapısını kırmaya çalışıyorlardı.
Sonunda kırdılar.
Peki neden inekler ahırın kapısını
kırdılar ki?
Bu soruya tekrar döneceğiz.
Şimdi size Hatice Teyze'den
bahsetmek istiyorum.
Hatice Teyze 65 yıl yaşadı.
Bu dünyada 3 çocuk doğurdu.
Yokluk ve sefaletle.
65 yılın sonunda Hatice Teyze
vefat etti.
Bedenini evinin salonunda, tek başına,
köylüler farketti.
Okutup büyüttüğü 3 çocuğu
yıllar önce Hatice Teyze'yi terk etmişti.
Hatice Teyze'nin cenazesi
evinden çıkarıldı,
komşular tarafından
ve işte tam o an kırıldı ahırın kapısı.
Yıllarca yalnızlığa itilen
Hatice Teyze'nin
ölümüne dayanamayıp, kahrolup ahırın
kapısını kırarken,
Hatice Teyze'nin inekleri ahırın
kapısını kırarken
çocuklarının bu ölümden haberleri
dahi olmadı.
Peki evcil hayvan deyince aklımıza
hangi canlılar geliyor?
Kedi, köpek, kuş.
Ya birbirimize hakaret için kullandığımız
eşek, inek ...
İneklerinin Hatice Teyze'ye olan
sevgilerinin
milyonda birini eğer bizler tüm
canlılara karşı besleyebilsek
bütün kötülükleri yok edebiliriz.
Ya dostlarımız?
Onlar hayatımızın neresindeler?
Biz hayatı onlarla paylaşabiliyor muyuz?
Evet, onlar diye hitap ettiğimiz engel
miydi bize?
Sevgi var oldukça asla uzak
değildir yaşantınıza.
Bende çok severeken paylaştım hayatımı.
Çocukluğumda başlayan hayvan sevgim
bir süre sonra yaşanılan engelleri
görebilmemi sağladı.
Engelli olan hayvanların
yaşantılarına sıçramaya
ve kendimi orada bulmaya başladım.
Müsadenizle bazı dostlarımı
göstermek istiyorum.
''Bu sekilde kızım yürüyecek.
Evet, hadi bakalım.
Hadi canım. Hadi bir tanem.
Yavaş. At adımını.
At canım adımını !
Aferin benim bir taneme.
Aferin!
Aferin aşkıma! Aferin,
kurban olurum sana.
Hadi, devam et!
Aferin! Aferin!''
(Müzik)
(Alkışlar)
Hayvanları sevdikçe birbirimize
karşı olan
sevgimizde artacak.
Ve dünya var olduğunu kanıtlayacak.
Biz, insanoğlu, birbirimize değer
vermeye başlayacağız.
Burada karşılaştığım
birinden bahsedeceğim.
Mutluluğumu arttıran kişilerden
biriydi.
Hattap.
''Karşınızda Hasan.
Nam-ı diğer Hayat Tamircisi.
Hasan bugüne kadar kullanılmayan
oyuncak ve demir parçalarından
yaptığı yürüteçlerle
yüzlerce sevimli dostumuzu
hayata bağladı.
Şimdi ise aldığı ufacık bir
teknoloji desteği ile en yakın
arkadaşının
imkânsız gibi görünen bir isteğini
gerçekleştirmek üzere.
''Hoşgeldin Hattap! ''
''Hoşbulduk abi.''
''Hattap bu kutuda senin için
bir sürpriz var.
Umarım beğenirsin.
Hazır mısın?
Alsana Hattap.''
(Müzik)
''Allah senden razı olsun.''
''Artık senin yeni kolun.
Beğendin mi?''
''Çok beğendim abi.''
''Aç-kapa bakayım.''
''Çok iyi.''
''Allah senden razı olsun.''
''Sana bir sürprizim daha var.''
''Hattapcım selamlar.
Duydum ki en büyük arzun
gitar çalmakmış.
Hasan sayesinde bu arzunu
gerçekleştirebileceksin.
Şimdi sana imzalı bir gitar
gönderiyorum.
Bu gitarla sürekli çalış ve asla
vazgeçme.''
Bazen küçük bir sürpriz kendinden
çok daha büyük
güzelliklere yol açabilir.
Biz bu sürprizi ''Hayat Tamircisi'' Hasan
ile birlikte
Hattap için hazırladık.
Artık Hattap hayalindeki gibi
gitar çalmaya bir adım daha yaklaştı.
Teknolojinin gücü tüm engelleri
kaldırsın diye
desteğimiz her zaman Hasan ve daha
nicelerinin yanında.''
(Alkışlar)
Bana ''Hayat Tamircisi'' diyorlar.
Aslında gerçek ''Hayat Tamircileri''
onlar.
Dünyanın dengesini koruyan ve
ekosistemin devamını sağlayandır
gerçek ''Hayat Tamircileri''.
Bildiğim tek şey şu:
Şu anda buradayız.
Toprağın bu tarafındayken elimizden
geleni yapalım derim.
Toprağın diğere tarafında çok
pişman olacağız.
O yüzden bir an önce bütün canlılara
insanlık için çalışmalıyız.
Beni dinlediğiniz için
çok teşekkürler.
(Alkışlar)
Sizce buraya sürprizsiz çıkmış
olabilir miyim?
Hattap aramızda.
(Müzik)
(Alkışlar)
Çok teşekkürler.
(Alkış)
Görüşürüz. İyilikle Kalın !